ah c'est la question qui tue est ce que
vous aviez eu à choisir donc entre d'une
part vivre en arabie saoudite
cloîtraient avec vos enfants ou quitter
l'arabie saoudite et vivre sans vos
enfants est-ce que des fois vous vous
dites pas j'aurais mieux fait de rester
en arabie saoudite parce que je serai
toujours avec mes enfants je me dis ça
tous les matins je vous dis ça tous les
matins et tous les matins quand je parle
à mes enfants j'ai alors demandé de me
pardonner d'oeuvre d'avoir décidé de
partir parce que je ne pouvais plus être
une bonne mère où je pensais qu'à la fin
je vais devenir une mère folle et mais
je sais aujourd'hui ma force de
résistance des telles que j'aurais pu
rester et d'ailleurs mon fils aîné me
dit jusqu'à présent moment qui est parti
trop tôt or à vue